[Music]
got a plan we've lost a space legend
astronaut John Glenn has died at the age
of 95 in 1962 Glenn became the first
American to enter orbit firing into the
fringes of space aboard the friendship 7
craft he spent five hours up there
traveling at over 17,000 miles per hour
before splashing down safely in the
ocean at the height of the Cold War and
the space race the feat made Glenn an
American hero and laid the groundwork
for sending Americans to the moon
President John F Kennedy decided Glenn
was so important that he refused to
assign him any more missions not one for
desk duty
Glenn left NASA and got into politics
serving as a US Senator for two decades
also not one for staying put on earth in
1998 Glenn convinced NASA to fire him
back into orbit this time aboard the
space shuttle that made him the oldest
person ever to go to space he spent
another 200 hours up there in space time
that's 134 sunsets and sunrises and once
again he returned safely to earth Glenn
was a champion of the human endeavor and
his impacts on the exploration of space
were in measurable so God's be John
Glenn God's being
you